principio de acuerdo en la primera ronda
de negociaciones en ciudad de méxico
donde gobierno y oposición venezolana
pactaron actuar juntos para facilitar la
llegada de vacunas al país y paliar los
efectos de la pandemia desbloqueando
activos en el extranjero que se refiere
principalmente a la necesidad de que
venezuela rescate recupere los activos y
recupere el dinero que se encuentra
depositado en cuentas en el extranjero y
que no le pertenecen a nadie más sino a
cada mujer y a cada hombre de la
república bolivariana de venezuela por
otro lado ambas partes pactaron defender
la soberanía sobre la guayana esequiba
un territorio que venezuela reivindica
aunque está bajo control de guyana la
oposición recordó que tal y como se
estableció hace tres semanas al firmar
el memorando de las siete bases del
diálogo no hay nada acordado hasta que
esté todo acordado en esta ronda se han
hablado algunos temas específicos pero
todavía no hemos entrado
todos los presos políticos que existen
en venezuela o exiliados o perseguidos
mientras los tímidos progresos avanzan
en ciudad de méxico en caracas se
mantiene la tensión el presidente
aseguró este domingo en una entrevista
que vayan como vayan los diálogos no
habrá impunidad para el opositor why do
aquí tiene que haber justicia
justicia severa porque es mucho el daño
que le han hecho a la vida de la familia
venezolana de la gente común de la gente
de a pie la próxima cita en méxico entre
ambas partes es el 24 de septiembre en
la agenda el sistema judicial la
constitución y la crisis económica